how's it going everybody its Warren and
there have been some updates to the huge
rumor about Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
possibly been in Avengers endgame so in
the first video that I did about this I
explained the news that was going around
and why everybody was freaking out
basically what happened was if you went
to Google and you searched Hugh Jackman
famous movies Avengers endgame popped up
so of course everybody started to freak
out saying that Wolverine is going to be
an Avengers endgame and due to all the
hype that it had and due to the fact
that you could find it on Google if you
searched for it everybody started to say
that it's confirmed but the reality of
it was it was never confirmed at all now
I'm sure that if Marvel and Disney
wanted Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and
Avengers in-game badly enough they could
make it happen Disney has done deals
with Fox before to allow them to use
characters that they do not own the
rights to in MCU movies but
unfortunately like I said there has been
an update on whether or not Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine will be appearing in
Avengers endgame if you go to google
right now and you search Hugh Jackman
famous movies Avengers in game no longer
appears Hugh Jackman's Wolverine being
and Avengers in game was also on a
Wikipedia page as well but if you search
for that it is also gone I said this in
my last video but if enough people
search for something on Google Google
will eventually Auto populate it so what
happened was a ton of people went onto
Google and searched Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in Avengers in game so
eventually google paired Hugh Jackman
and Avengers in game together so when
you searched Hugh Jackman famous movies
Avengers and game popped up so again
this was in no way a confirmation I
would personally love to see Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine in the MCU
nonetheless in Avengers in game and
although it is possible and there are
ways that Disney and Marvel could bring
Wolverine into Avengers in game I just
don't think they should and there's an
extremely high chance that they won't
we've watched our heroes over the past
ten years and Avengers in game is going
to be about these heroes that we've come
to love they're not going to introduce a
huge character like Wolverine in a movie
supposed to wrap up the first 10 years
of the MCU could Hugh Jackman appear in
Avengers in-game as a different
character absolutely could he appear in
the post-credit scene yes but we're not
going to see his Wolverine character in
Avengers in game especially since the
Disney Fox deal isn't done yet and
Avengers in game has been completely
filmed so sorry to deliver this update
to you trust me I was super sad when I
found out this news as well but it
doesn't seem like we'll be seeing Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and Avengers in game
however there are still rumors going
around that he may appear in Avengers in
game but not as Wolverine
so if he does make an appearance what
character do you think he'll be playing
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and my Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway continues if you would
like to enter the giveaway for your
chance to win a life-size Infinity
Gauntlet all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]